maintenant il ya plus de vingt-cinq
crise humanitaire majeure qui frappe la
planète actuellement que ce soit lié à
des conflits ou au climat ces crises en
tous cas sont évidemment très complexe
on va faire le bilan avec notre invité
en studio françois audet il est
directeur de l'observatoire canadien sur
les crises et l'action humanitaire
monsieur od bonjour bonjour je voulais
peut-être faire coller notre discussion
avec l'actualité avec encore une fois un
garçon de 8 ans un guatémaltèque qui est
mort dans les mains en fait des services
douaniers américains
ça c'est une crise qui continue
d'alimenter les manchettes et c'est une
crise réelle à ces migrants d'amérique
latine
oui oui et en fait la vraie tragédie
c'est que ce sera le deuxième enfant qui
serait mort comme vous l'avait dit dans
l'est dans les mains des deux des
services sociaux américains
c'est d'autant plus troublant on parle
pas d'enfant de la guerre ou deux sont
morts de famine ou yémen on pourrait
reparler mais oui donc la crise
migratoire de qui frappe l'ensemble de
l'amérique latine proviennent notamment
un peu du venezuela dit si l'amérique
centrale ont beau avec le déplacement
des cartes est l'un des narcotrafiquants
d'amérique centrale où mexico
beaucoup veulent remonter la frontière
vers l'est vers les états unis
et on sait avec le président actuel donc
il ya un mur dans tous les sens du terme
qui se bâtit à la frontière certains ont
réussi à rentrer il ya une gestion très
difficile actuellement la frontière est
malheureusement de manière très
surprenante
un deuxième enfant serait mort on sait
pas encore de quoi celui ce dernier
malheureusement la première petite fille
c'était pour des raisons de manque d'eau
carrément donc il ya une surabondance
dans les airs dans les espaces qu'on
leur donne le faire très chaud très mal
ventilée et il ya déshydratation
malheureusement alors on verra pour le
second un petit garçon qu'est ce qui
s'est passé il ya évidemment le disait
plus d'une vingtaine de crise
humanitaire majeure il y en a plus que
c'est évidemment mais les majeurs qui
nous préoccupe il fera plus d'un million
de personnes c'est comme ça qu'on les
qualifie c'est énorme effectivement on
parlait du yémen soudan du sud venezuela
sont les trois grosses oui le yémen
actuellement est qualifié par jour elle
à la communauté de pratique avec lequel
je collabore comme étant la plus
importante est actuellement ses 22
millions de personnes 22 millions de
personnes s'est plusieurs fois la
population du québec c'est c'est un
énorme
22 millions de personnes dont qui sont
en demande quotidienne des aides
humanitaires dead alimentaires
médicaments et cetera 2 millions
personnes déplacées à l'inter dans un
pays en guerre donc le yémen qui te
plaît en guerre depuis quelques années
donc c'est pas cette année n'est pas
l'année où le conflit a émergé mais avec
une année très violente et pour
lesquelles on ne voit pas poindre non
plus de résolutions
alors malheureusement un 2019 s'avère va
s'avérer très difficile pour ces 22
millions de yéménites là qui sont
coincés littéralement dans le pays parce
qu'il ya très peu de difficulté très
très d'accéder le conflit fait rage
alors les humanitaires dans ce temps là
les nations unies ne peuvent pas rentrer
dans des zones de combat évidemment il
ya d'autres crises aussi qu'ils sont
tout aussi majeur mais qui pense
peut-être en arrière c'est que c'est
comme chaque année ya des nouvelles
crises fait qu'on oublie les autres
voilà mais la syrie par exemple assez
loin des terrains terrible loin d'être
terminée on en a beaucoup parlé pour des
raisons tout à fait évidente notamment
ici avec la l'ouverture qu'ont eue pour
recevoir le quarante mille réfugiés
syriens il ya quelques années la série
donc moins déterminé on a gagné du
terrain on étend donc l'occident
notamment la coalition nature du terrain
sur l'état islamique a fait qui a perdu
un peu des plumes mais les factions sur
place le l'équilibré régional et local
n'a pas encore été établie encore
beaucoup de combats
ça reste encore aujourd'hui une
perspective humanitaire donc entre cinq
et six millions de personnes déplacées
en syrie est à peu près l'équivalent aux
frontières opportune aux pourtours
notamment en turquie au liban et dans
les pays limitrophes donc une douzaine
de millions de personnes actuellement
qui demande encore de l'aide de l'aide
humanitaire pour survivre et anglais non
plus tout comme le yémen 2019 ne sera
pas une année positive pour la série on
n'a pas dû ni pollution dans les
pourparlers pour la paix dont la
population est encore dépendante de
l'aide
un mot en terminant sur son appel de
peut-être les réfugiés climatiques ont
tout cas les victimes de catastrophes
naturelles et autres
ça aussi il faut il faut surveiller ça
oui tout à fait c'est une vague de fond
malheureusement qu'on voit poindre
depuis quelques années
lorsque le climat est en jeu maintenant
on est ce que ce que la science nous dit
c'est que il n'ya pas y'a pas une telle
chose que d'une catastrophe naturelle à
part ces listes mais qu évidemment comme
on l'a vu avec le tsunami
mais lorsqu'il ya des sécheresses des
sécheresses vont engendrer des tensions
sociales des tensions avec les groupes
de producteurs agricoles des combats des
conflits et c'est donc là la catastrophe
naturelle ne venez pas ne reconnais pas
n'est pas unique en soi donc ça c'est ça
donnait toujours très complexe par la
suite tensions sociales et donc oui on
indique aujourd'hui qu'hier entre deux
et trois millions de personnes qui
migrent pour le climat donc pour des
raisons essentiellement me et
climatiques aujourd'hui notamment en
afrique bien des sources d'inquiétude
encore une fois en 2019 merci beaucoup
françois audet ça me fait
malheureusement plaisir d'être ici
merci encore